[Music]  cover mechanic right  [Music]  you you're crate are safe now oh hey  welcome to spectacular sunset city okay  here's the situation  a contaminated energy drink has turned  everyone into mutants there are  survivors doing whatever they can to get  by but some of them are dicks attacking  others for their stuff well just ignore  that one  good it's not all bad how this place  needs is a hero one who doesn't just  survive but he does it it's tough who is  this hero me nah not me oh you can you  survive the many dangers  can you help others survive can you save  sunset City can you for the love of God  can you  [Applause]  of course again it's a video game  [Music]  [Music]